the Gaff prone Biden Administration gave
Americans a potential glimpse into the
future this week when the president gave
a joint press conference with Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis and allowed
DeSantis to speak from a lectern bearing
the presidential seal when I first saw
the photos of President DeSantis going
viral my first thought was that some
poor schlub on the White House Advance
team was probably having a very very
unpleasant afternoon probably getting
chewed out by Biden's chief of staff for
the gaffe that framed DeSantis as a
potential future president
but then something even stranger
happened
Biden complimented DeSantis
what the governor's done is pretty
remarkable Biden said I think he's done
a good job we worked hand in glove we
have very different political
philosophies but we've worked hand in
glove now
DeSantis has done a terrific job on
Hurricane preparation and recovery so I
am sure in part Biden just wants to
associate himself with that success if
he can't beat him join him but that does
not explain why Biden would be so
effusive in his praise
certainly was not because Biden is
sincere or gives credit where credit is
due this is the same guy who told black
voters that milk toast Mitt Romney
wanted to put them back in Chains
Joe Biden is a mean nasty partisan
so why is he being so nice to DeSantis
the lectern might have been an accident
the public praise suggests to me a
strategy
seems to me Biden and his team at least
his team I don't know if Biden makes any
of these decisions himself but at least
the team
has made a conscious decision to build
up Ron DeSantis and it makes perfect
sense DeSantis is currently the biggest
threat to Joe Biden's biggest threat who
is Donald Trump
as Democrat policies plunge America into
poverty chaos and possibly even World
War III the best shot the Democrats have
at retaining power is to divide the
Republicans and again I'm not saying
anything about Trump or DeSantis in a
general election I'm just saying you
look at the polls Trump is at the top of
the heat by a long shot DeSantis is the
number two guy so the best way the
Democrats can divide Republicans is to
egg on a trump DeSantis shooting match
as early as possible you're already
seeing some sniping around the periphery
as Democrats get more desperate expect
surprisingly kind words for the governor
of Florida I'm Michael Knowles is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Frank s Who
Says with the holidays coming up it's
important you know how to talk to
conspiracy theorists in your family
first look them in the eye
second shake their hand third apologize
profusely so true so true man because
all those people who have been derided
as horrible conspiracy theorist cranks
with tinfoil hats they have a much
better record than pretty much all the
political experts and Eggheads and
scientists and all the rest of it so yes
you should when you are speaking with
your family this holiday season and
there's that crazy uncle that crazy
right-wing Uncle at your table just say
you're sorry
when you're speaking with your family
before the holidays come around you're
going to want to check out pure talk
right now head on over to puretalk.com
enter code Knowles the government is
addicted to spending this the spending
is driving up the cost of everything
it's not fair I know it's not fair but
you don't have to be a victim there are
things that you can do right now to
lower your monthly expenses and mitigate
the impact of inflation one this is the
simplest one switch your cell phone
service to Pure Talk take a look at your
cell phone bill if you are with Verizon
ATT or T-Mobile I know how much you pay
I've seen those bills you're paying way
too much if your talk will give you
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just thirty dollars a month that
could be a huge savings for you and your
family that's grocery money that's gas
money Pure Talk never raises their rates
by switching to Pure Talk the average
family of four is saving over 75 dollars
every single month customers are
realizing they just don't need as much
data as they're being sold right now
okay join the hundreds of thousands of
people who are making the switch to pure
talk today when you switch to pure talk
with my special discount you will get 50
off your first month just go to
puretalk.com choose your plan enter code
Knowles Canada w-l-e-s
puretalk.com enter code Knowles for 50
off your first month
what a news day
yesterday I I've been on the road I've
been traveling like crazy I was in Las
Vegas yesterday with Senator Cruz we've
got a big announcement on verdict coming
up so you're going to want to check that
out it's an announcement that I've kind
of been foreshadowing for a little while
but it's an announcement nevertheless
you should go check out so I was in
Vegas my head was kind of out of the
news and then I'm getting on the
airplane to come back to Nashville last
night and I see I see a lot of big
stories but the most important one as
far as I'm concerned
Mr Yeezy Kanye West goes on Tucker
Carlson it's an extremely wide-ranging
interview we can't get to all of it but
he Kanye West
makes
an incredibly a beautiful actually
eloquent and precise argument for life
and even just beyond life and the
abortion issue for for a a whole view of
politics take a listen
so you just came from Paris Fashion Week
you just landed in the lanyard and still
on from it and there's a photograph on
it what is that it's a photograph of a
baby's ultrasound
why is that and that you designed that
yes why what does that mean uh it just
represents life and pro-life
boy so you wear it on a badge what what
kind of response do you and and good
amen I agree I don't care about people's
responses I care about the fact that
there's more
black babies being aborted than born in
New York City at this point that 50 of
Black Death
in America is abortion so I really don't
care about people's responses I perform
for audience at one and that's God
wow wow his his pro-life message superb
and and it's it's more important that
Kanye West this major cultural figure
maybe the most important cultural figure
of our era
I say this as someone don't listen to a
ton of pop music or hip-hop or anything
like that but the the guy was just
transformative within his own genre and
Industry and he's sort of transcended
his genre in industry and he's just a
force of nature in the culture
so very important that he says that
but that last line oh my gosh it just
shows you
Kanye's political insight
and spiritual insight for that matter he
says I don't care what other people say
I perform for an audience of one and
that's God
wow that's it write that down put put
that write that down on the back of your
hand so that you can just look at that
anytime you get confused in politics or
your personal life or anything else a
lot of people will tell you they'll give
you the opposite version the kind of
inverse of that of that Maxim they'll
say I don't care what other people think
I'll I perform for an audience of one
and that's me you know I don't care what
other people think I'm just gonna do
what I want to do I'm gonna live my
truth I'm going to be authentic to
myself but that's dumb that's stupid
you're just as fallen and corrupted and
broken as anybody else
Kanye says no no you don't
you don't live for the crowds that's
dumb and you don't live just for
yourself you're performing for an
audience of one and that's God God the
essence of being truth goodness and
Beauty that's what you're living for
baby that's it your creator your maker
the the omnipotent King of the universe
who holds all of our lives in his hands
and and on on whom we we rely for every
breath that we breathe that's who you
that's who you're performing for
everything else is just crap you could
you could win a zillion cars and a ton
of money in big houses you could you
could become I don't know governor of a
state president of the United States
none of that matters if you're not
living a life of sanctity if you're not
moving towards sanctification and
Holiness because ultimately you're going
to turn to worm food and you're going to
take a dirt nap so you're the only
audience that it matters that you're
performing for is God and Kanye West
gets it and I feel totally freaking
Vindicated because I I have been very
Pro Kanye for many years now and I made
the point I looked it up on Twitter I
made the point a couple of years ago two
or three years ago I said Kanye West has
greater political Insight than the vast
majority of elected politicians and
journalists and certainly all those
people at the New York Times
and he does it's true Kanye West it has
more political insight and is doing more
political good not just than the
majority of politicians but then the
majority of elected Republicans than the
majority of conservatives and at the
time when Kanye West first started
making these kinds of conservative
noises you know started to suggest he
might be bucking the trends here on on
some of these left-wing matters
there were a lot of a lot of the people
liked it but a lot of the kind of
professional conservative types you know
the the Beltway types they said uh oh we
don't like this he's not one of us you
know Kanye West he never even had an
internship on Capitol Hill you know
Kanye West he doesn't even wear tweed to
to think tanks and so he's not I don't
know I think we ought to keep this guy
at arm's length and I said no this guy
is getting it yeah maybe he's saying
some things that are a little weird here
and there he's kind of coming into it
now he's figuring out what he thinks but
the guy's heart is in the right place
and and his his vision is in the right
place he's looking at the right thing
and he's trying to figure it out now
actually some of this began with Candace
Owens you remember Kanye tweeted out
something to the effect of I love the
way Candace's mind works all right like
I like the way Candace Owen thinks or
some something like that and so I think
she played a role there there were other
people who played a role Kanye just the
other day tweeted out the trailer to
Candace's movie
so we here at Daily wire daily wire Plus
have this movie coming up the greatest
lie ever sold it's this the story the
real amazing story of George Floyd and
the BLM movement that came out of George
Floyd and I've gotten to see the cuts of
it obviously it hasn't come out yet
it's going to be available exclusively
at Daily wire plus so if you're not a
member sign up now but it gives you a
perspective that just you just haven't
seen anywhere you haven't seen it in the
left-wing media obviously you probably
haven't seen it in the right wing media
and and it's a perspective I think
really only Candace elements can give
and which is why we we love that we have
her here at Daily wire and but but
that's the kind of message that cuts
through all of the noise and Kanye saw
that now Kanye is just totally expanding
the political imagination
much more so than your average Egghead
at a think tank much more so than your
average Beltway staff or professional
Republican on Capitol Hill or at the RNC
or something like that
Kanye by the way is not only shifting
people away from the left toward the
right he's also helping clarify what the
right should think because for a long
time the right side you know enough of
that God talk enough of those cultural
issues you got to stay away from that
let's just talk about tax cuts and it
was so dumb and all we ever did was lose
back when the Republicans talked like
that and Kanye West is saying no
no uh-uh we're gonna stand up for life
we're gonna stand up for our culture
we're going to say White lives matter
because we're going to we're why did
Kanye say White lives matter he said
because blm's a scam and everybody knows
it and now it's over and you're welcome
there's exact words okay we're gonna do
that we're and and ult we're going to
stand up for the most important thing of
all we're going to say we're gonna
Orient our country back toward God we're
going to orient our individual Vision
back toward God and our country back
toward God that's what we did that's how
the country started that's what made the
country great we turned our eyes away
from God that's why the country looks
like crap right now and if we want to
fix it if we want to make America great
again we've got to put our eyes back
where they belong and have our actions
follow that Vision 100 love it great
stuff Kanye
the other huge news story that came out
yesterday is that talk about opposites
you know talk about contrasts so you've
got Kanye West saying defend life be
good pursue virtue yeah sure I'm a
fallen man I've made all sorts of
mistakes but come on we got to just go
do the right thing look toward God
perform for an audience of one and then
what do you have Joe Biden doing Joe
Biden lets drug dealers out of prison
that's his big announcement take a
listen
as I said when I ran for president no
one should be in jail just for using or
possessing marijuana it's already legal
in many states and criminal records for
marijuana possession have led to
needless barriers to employment to
housing and educational opportunities
and that's before you address the racial
disparities around who suffers the
consequences while white and black and
brown people use marijuana in similar
rates black and brown people are
arrested prosecuted and convicted at
disproportionately higher rates so today
I'm taking three steps to end this
failed approach first I'm announcing a
pardon for all prior federal offense
Federal offenses for the simple
possession of marijuana second I'm
calling on all governors to do the same
for State marijuana possession offenses
third the federal government currently
classifies marijuana as a schedule one
substance the same as heroin LSD and
more serious than fentanyl makes no
sense
so I'm asking the Secretary of Health
and Human Services and the Attorney
General to initiate a process to review
how marijuana is scheduled under federal
law too many lives have been upended
because of our failed approach to
marijuana it's time that we right these
wrongs it's time that we right these
wrongs we're going to let the people out
of prison for simple possession now
you're going to say Michael Michael you
just said that Biden's letting drug
dealers out of prison but that's not
what Biden said Biden said he's just
letting the people out who are in jail
for simple possession
right that's what he said
the problem is statistically speaking
pretty much nobody is in jail for simple
possession
there are there are some people who are
a small number of people who are in jail
ostensibly for simple possession
but most of the time the vast majority
of the time it's they're not really in
jail for simple possession they've taken
plea deals because the people were had
amounts of marijuana that they could
sell even if they only had small amounts
they were selling these are drug dealers
these are traffickers these are people
involved in the drug trade and then they
go in and especially because we've we've
liberalized all of our drug laws these
weak prosecutors go in and they plead it
down and they say okay we're not going
to get you for trafficking we're not
going to get you for peddling poison to
kids we're just going to say it was
simple possession but you're going to go
to jail for that so in practice there's
a really good survey on this by the
Hudson Institute that came out a few
years ago go check it out in the Hudson
Institute website
in practice what this means is Joe Biden
is going to be letting drug dealers out
of prison
okay and again the number of people who
are in federal prisons for for drug
offense is very very small compared to
the state prisons but why is Biden doing
this why is Biden letting drug dealers
in practice out of prison during the
worst drug crisis in American history
where where the the drug crisis is so
bad that the life expectancy of the
United States is actually decreasing
because of overdoses and suicides and
deaths of despair
a big part of that is overdoses why
it's a classic Democrat strategy let the
criminals out of prison it's a classic
left-wing strategy
they've been doing it since the French
Revolution you let the criminals out of
prison
you you expand Vice you expand political
chaos and that will allow you to take
more power Biden also knows going into
the midterm elections he's got nothing
the economy is in the gutter the the
energy prices which he which had spiked
to all-time highs in some places and
then they had started to come down a
little so Biden initially said it's not
my fault that energy prices are high up
even though it was his fault largely
then they started to go down a little he
said it's all thanks to me that the
energy prices are starting to come down
a little tiny bit but now they're going
back up again now they've reached record
highs again you look in California
they've never seen prices like this all
of a sudden Bine says it's not my fault
again Biden has drained the Strategic
petroleum reserve it has not been this
low in many decades and he's done that
to try to bring the prices down and that
still hasn't really succeeded and so now
he's increased the amenities releasing
out of the Strategic petroleum Reserve
which is really in paralleling National
Security but that still doesn't get him
across the Finish Line then you've got
the fact that we are in a recession the
Biden admination doesn't want to admit
it but we are in a recession two
consecutive quarters of negative GDP
growth we're we're in a recession folks
and you've got the first major war in
Europe since World War II now
threatening nuclear war
and and not only is Russia saber
rattling but the West is openly talking
about potential nuclear war so it's just
Things Are
terrible you look at the social issues
right now what is Biden running on he's
running on killing more babies which is
not really helping the Democrats not
nearly as much as they thought it would
and they're running on transiting the
kids deeply deeply unpopular it's just I
mean we could be here all day if we
talked about every issue that they're
losing on and so the the nearest thing
that Biden can do the the easiest thing
we can do to try to Gin up his base is
to free some criminals you know his base
and to to lie about a public policy
issue say these poor people they're just
it's just some poor kid who was trying
one joint for the first time and he was
probably black and he was nabbed by
racist cops and given a life sentence in
prison none of that ever happened the
people Biden's talking about are drug
dealers nasty rotten people who are
poisoning your kids and killing
Americans he's going to let them out of
prison and he thinks it's going to help
him and I just don't think it will
I think it's wrong to do and I just
don't think it's going to help him that
much speaking of political stunts in
this case more
I think more successful political stunts
a concerned mother Timothy rakes oh not
Timothy Timothy that's it that's sort of
the amalgam that's the androgynous name
of Kimberly and Timothy now Kimberly
rakes the founder of a parental rights
group at Iowa Mama bears just showed up
to a school board meeting at Ankeny High
School
and she was she referred to this insane
incident that occurred at the school
where the gay straight Alliance Club the
sort of LGBT propaganda Club at the high
school invited drag queen performers to
to perform for the kids for their
end-of-year meeting and so Kimberly
rakes shows up wearing the outfit
that the drag queen wore take a listen
ing
because this guy walked into our school
doing it Kimberly can you dress up
this is what this is like in front of
our kids so this makes your head spit
this pisses you off in any way shape or
or it should because I'm embarrassed to
stand here in the outfit that I am at
today but I have a point to prove and
that is that this outfit should not be
ever accepted in our stores anyway
ma'am please please put that that out
for that that's obscene that's
pornographic that belongs in a strip
club
right
right that that's true
so why can't why can a why is it wrong
for a mother at the school so someone
who's in the school Community a woman to
show up wearing women's clothing
that's kind of scandalous and risque
that's unacceptable ma'am sit down
please change put some clothes on
but when a dude like a big fat pervert
dude who has no connection to people at
the school shows up wearing the exact
same women's clothing that's wonderful
that needs to be celebrated that's so
great why is it that transgender people
or drag queens or any of these confused
men why is it that they get to do
whatever the hell they want and that is
wonderful and celebrated
why is that that doesn't make any sense
at all
and the woman I thought she made a
beautiful point
and even for us I think even we've
become kind of desensitized to it oh
there are those weird drag queens again
well it's like the joke and Family Guy
where there's the transvestite sitting
in a bar and the bartender comes up and
says ma'am you can't look at pornography
You Know download pornography at this
bar and he dressed up as a woman says oh
no no I'm transgender and the bartender
says oh okay then you can do whatever
you want right why is that why do but
you see the woman you're like Whoa man
that's weight that's way too sexual to
be around kids that's totally
inappropriate right it is
how much more inappropriate is it for
some weirdo dude to show up and prey on
little kids like this of course anyone
any adult who had any foreknowledge of
the drag queen event needs to be fired
from the school for sure and then the
this club the gay gay straight Alliance
certainly needs to be disbanded at this
high school if if not at other high
schools as well and we just can't we
need to take a much harder stand on this
because the radical LGBT activists are
never going to stop until we are all
wearing the rainbow flag you know the
corporate media agenda
means that the news is presented in a
very biased way you know it I know we
all know it well fortunately there is a
way to get the most important news of
the day without their narrative and that
is by listening to one of the top news
podcasts morning wire new episodes are
available every morning seven days a
week they cover stories that other media
Outlets will not touch starting this
Sunday October 9th and every Sunday
until the midterm elections you can also
tune into election wire for in-depth
coverage candidate interviews and more
it's the most important midterm election
in recent history stand formed you will
find morning wire and election wire on
Apple podcast Spotify daily wire Plus or
wherever you listen to podcasts
the radical LGBT activists are not going
to stop until you and everybody else
are waving the rainbow flag mark my
words how do I know this because of poor
Jack Phillips
You Know Jack Phillips
his case his cases have made it to
courts around the country all the way up
to the highest court in the land
Jack Phillips has appeared on this show
he's the owner of masterpiece cake shop
he is a really nice soft-spoken Earnest
Christian guy who was asked to create
cakes specifically for a gay wedding
quote unquote and he said oh I'm sorry I
can't participate in a gay wedding
because I'm Christian and so you know
you can go to there's a gay cake shop
down the street the honors are super pro
gay stuff and so they'll it's no big
deal you just go down there it'll be
fine and what happened the radical LGBT
activists sued this guy and tried to
destroy his business
unfortunately he was able to win that
case
but he said he wasn't saying I won't
serve customers who have eccentric
sexual views I won't serve gay guys who
come in to buy a cake but he said I I
can't make a cake specifically for your
gay wedding I can't you can't force me
to use my art my craft to participate in
a ceremony that I consider to be sinful
and contrary to my religious views there
are plenty of other cake shops that will
do why are you guys so focused on making
me kneel down and worship at your altar
and why are you so
interested in making me violate my
Christian views when there were so many
other options for you because it's not
about the cake and it's not about the
wedding it's about making the Christians
get down and do what they're told right
that's that's what this is really about
and the way you know this for certain is
that
after Jack Phillips took a huge
financial loss really hurt his business
but he he prevails in court
well he's in court again
is the activists are going after him
again because after his Supreme Court
victory
he gets a call from a woman quote
unquote it's really a man named Autumn
scardina who calls Phillips
and requests a birthday cake that had
blue frosting on the outside and pink
frosting on the inside to celebrate his
gender transition
and he says
obvious here we go again you know you
know that this wasn't about the cake
there are plenty of other cake shops but
this radical trans activist calls this
guy to say oh we didn't beat you last
time we're going to beat you this time
make celebrate my sexual delusion
celebrate it do it do it now bigot
you're gonna do it you stupid Christian
we're gonna make you do it we're gonna
use the force of the law and so he's in
court again I hope he wins I don't know
it I it's totally up in the air this
poor man at first before I met Jack
Phillips I thought is this guy just is
he a political activist who's really
just trying to put himself in these
situations and
he's not he's ju he's just a soft-spoken
nice Baker who keeps getting targeted by
these vicious people these vicious LGBT
activists who obviously hate Christians
and don't want to allow Christians to
practice their religion and and just are
they're so confident in their sexual
identity that they demand that every
last person in this country
affirm their way of life and their
delusions that's how confident they are
that if even one person even thinks like
um I actually don't think you're really
maybe totally a woman even one person
thinks that that's a that's an
existential threat we've got to bring
Jack Phillips to his needs
they're not going to stop and so
everyone's going to try to find some
Middle Ground like oh well you know
actually let's just support we can
redefine marriage in this way but not in
this way and let's just go halfway and
look we can I'll refer to Caitlyn Jenner
as Caitlyn because you can change your
name but I don't know if I'm willing to
I know that only at a certain age are
you willing no guys guys it's not
there's no there's no middle ground here
on questions of ultimate truth and like
ontology and I'll just quick basic
questions of the of being and human
nature you've got to just pick a side
and stand for the truth Kanye can do it
why can't you
why can't you because you think oh well
we'll meet halfway okay I'll bet what if
I bake a cupcake I'm not going to bake a
full cake but a cup no that's just not
either Christians yet to practice their
religion or they don't either men are
not women or men can be women I these
are there's no middle ground here okay
you've got to just pick a side and have
courage
and just take a lesson from Yeezy okay
speaking of attacks
on on conservative businesses
this is not just a handful of activists
who are attacking businesses we're
talking about some of the largest asset
managers the largest investing companies
in the entire world
are now using a specific platform called
ESG
but but other tactics as well to force
conservative businesses to go woke
and one of the biggest offenders of this
is Blackrock BlackRock huge huge uh a
fund manager right
um this is uh
you figure there's black rock there's
Vanguard there's State Street those are
kind of the three really big ones and so
how are they able to do this they're
able to do this because pretty much
everyone invests their money with them
retail investors University pensions uh
State Pension funds and so
there's great news now Louisiana has
said the Louisiana state treasurer John
Schroeder has said that Louisiana will
divest
nearly 800 million dollars in funds from
the asset management company BlackRock
specifically because of ESG they say
Louisiana says not only is this not in
keeping with our values
but this is just not right for the for
the people of Louisiana because because
BlackRock is putting their own radical
left political agenda above making money
in some cases and so what whatever it
takes whatever argument it takes good we
need the states we need the good
conservative State treasurers
to pull their money out of these funds
because these these attacks are not
going to stop
just because we're complaining about
them they're going to stop when we get
leverage and political power and wield
that political power
now finally we have arrived at my
favorite time of the week when I get to
hear from all of you in the mailbag our
mailbag is sponsored by Pure Talk go to
puretalk.com select to plan enter promo
code Knowles to get 50 off your first
month let's take it away with a
voicemail bag
hey Michael my name is Kate I am happily
married with two young girls and we are
devout Christians who also love
celebrating Halloween so that brings me
to my question uh my sister-in-law
has recently started texting me my
husband the rest of the family these
articles and memes claiming that
Halloween is evil and even though we
celebrate Halloween at the church Fall
Fest instead of trick-or-treating she's
saying that quote it's okay to do evil
things if it's at church
um and that we're teaching our kids that
fitting in is more important than
Holiness
um
I mean my little girls want to be
princesses this year I don't I don't see
much evil in that
but I also you know as a Christian I
want to lead by example
um so what are your thoughts on this
let me know
Halloween is not evil you can do evil
things on Halloween just like you can do
evil things on any day of the week but
Halloween is not evil Halloween is the
the night before All Saints Day that's
what it means Halloween we get in
English because English has Latin roots
and German Roots you get the word uh Sun
like the word for Holiness comes from
Sanctus in Latin uh you know sanctity
sanctification and we also get hallow
from the German but it's the same thing
just means Holiness and uh because All
Saints Day has been celebrated for a
very very long time many centuries here
in the west uh the night the evening
before all science day is Halloween uh
some some people will claim that
Halloween is a pagan tradition uh this
is not true I mean in as much as you
hear these arguments all the time people
will claim that Christmas is actually
based on a pagan holiday that is also
not true I've done a few uh shows about
this that's made up actually the pagan
holiday that they say it is based on it
very very likely came out after
Christmas as a response to Christmas and
there's no there's certainly no evidence
that it predates Christmas uh and the
reason that Christmas is celebrated on
the day that it is has to do with
understandings of when the Annunciation
was the conception of Christ and the
length of a Divine Life and anyway it's
a little bit of a tangent but we can go
into it at some point
um so that's not true it's based it's
based on All Saints Day but furthermore
even if it were true
that is I I don't see what the problem
is if you can baptize pagan holidays and
I'm not saying that's what's going on
here but even if that were true that
that's sort of a good thing so if there
were some kind of Fall Festival a pagan
fall festival and then the Christians
came in and said actually this is going
to be All Saints Day now that's that's a
great thing that's a wonderful thing to
do uh in terms of what happens on
Halloween what happens you give kids
candy that's a nice thing to do you go
around and see your neighbors and you
know you wear fun costumes sometimes as
Saints sometimes as a princess or
whatever that seems fine and you carve
jack-o-lanterns that seems fine and so
yeah I don't recommend that you know you
all dress up as the devil and start you
know sinning left and right and you know
having kind of Satanic rituals but if
you're just celebrating Halloween is the
way that you're describing that sounds
wonderful next question
hey Michael shout out to Pure Talk and
love the show my question is regarding
kids and smartphones what do I do when
my kids reach that age where all of
their friends have smartphones and
access to the internet unfiltered Tick
Tock softcore Instagram porn and
goodness knows what is going to be
available to them in let's say eight to
ten years
um you know do I just shelter them
completely not give them one although
I'm sure they'll be able to access it
via their friends or do I give in and
let them have that access but monitor it
heavily or do I stick with old school
phones for contact for those
extracurricular activities I mean what
are parents supposed to do in this day
and age thanks Michael
old-school phone do not give your kid a
smartphone do not hear me now all who
have ears to hear Let Them hear do not
give your kid this portal to hell that
would be insane that would be completely
insane now my kids are not old enough
yet that I've had to deal with this
issue I know it's hard you know you want
the kid to fit in you don't want the kid
to seem like a weirdo you want right you
want your kid to be cool or whatever
I'm just telling you all the all the
kids that I know
of all the kids that I know of my
friends kids family members kids
as a rule the ones who have smartphones
have way more problems
and the kids the little perfect
wonderful kids that I know
they don't
of course of course not so yeah don't do
that this is a simple do not whatever
you do I'm trying to shake you through
the screen do not give your kids a
smartphone
all right next question
hi Michael
uh the other day I was talking to this
older man
um who said that he had worked in
the oil industry for all his life he
just recently retired from it and he had
said that he's now an independent voter
because Republicans control the gas
prices
and so when Republicans get into office
they lower it
and when Democrats get into office they
raise it and so he just doesn't trust
either side is what he said
and I was just curious if you had any
opinions or knowledge about this do you
think maybe the Republicans are not the
good guys that they're actually just
kind of tricking all of us into thinking
they're the good guys and we're all just
kind of ignorant to it thank you
there are plenty of reasons to be
skeptical of and angry at Republicans
but raising the gas prices is not one of
them that's that is not how gas prices
work so the little kernel of Truth and
what your friend said is that Isis I do
strongly suspect that Republicans are
are disproportionately represented in
the oil and gas industry especially
compared to every other industry which
is basically dominated by democrats so
yeah that's true there are a lot of a
lot of good old Texas Republicans who
are involved in the oil and gas industry
but no the way that it works is not that
that you know the oil companies just
kind of get together and decide in a
smoke-filled room what the price of gas
is going to be and then that's reflected
at all of the pumps that's not the way
it works also because the the oil and
gas industry is a global market and so
what determines the price of oil and gas
is much less the whims and Caprices of
of a few guys down in Texas it's much
more what's going on in Saudi Arabia
it's much more what's going on
throughout the oil Rich Middle East it's
much more what's going on in the war in
Ukraine if you want to blame one event
for the rise in Energy prices that would
be the war in Ukraine and who Bears
responsibility for the war in Ukraine I
think obviously Vladimir Putin is the
one who invaded Ukraine but I think if
you're going to blame someone's
Stateside it would have to be Joe Biden
and that's not just my opinion because
I'm a republican partisan or a
conservative or something like that
that's what Vladimir zielinski said
that's what the president of Ukraine
said he said that if Joe Biden lifts
these sanctions off of certain Russian
assets that is going to allow Russia to
invade and then and then Joe Biden
actually invited Russia to invade
Ukraine when he said if there's just a
minor incursion into the east of Ukraine
that won't be a really big deal so so he
is the one who did that and I think he
is directly responsible for these oil
prices going up of course it's not it's
not the Republicans I think your friend
I think your friend is somewhat deluded
in that regard plenty of other good
reasons to criticize Republicans but
that isn't one of them next next
question
hi to Mr Knowles I'm James George from
Texas and I have a couple questions for
you sir
uh one I haven't mean to get into uh
political commentary for a while but I
have trouble finding stories to stay
relevant long enough and plus just
finding stories so if y'all could help
me with that that'd be amazing but also
here's what you probably don't get asked
very often Mr Nostradamus what are your
opinions on motorcycles I absolutely
love them I have one in the garage I got
into an accident about like a month ago
by myself uh so I'm completely fine
that the bike's been out of shape though
I'm fixing it right now but I just love
riding it is so such a Zen theme
especially in the countryside and the
winding uh Hills of the Hill Country
that I live in oh so great it is so
great I actually kind of getting antsy
right now just thinking about it uh but
yeah I'd love to hear your opinions on
this uh uh keep up the good fight I look
forward to seeing you next episode
motorcycles are extremely cool
they're very dangerous and they're very
cool those two things often go hand in
hand so you've just got to take a sort
of risk analysis here but I know I got a
lot of friends and relatives who ride
motorcycles and I know a number of
people including among that group who
have been very seriously injured on
motorcycles but you know so if you're
gonna do it be careful wear a helmet you
know do your best to do it safely but
I've heard it's wonderful and when I've
when I've ridden on motorcycles it's
super cool definitely definitely very
cool as to how to help you get into
Political commentary so you're telling
me you don't just want me to write my
own show you want me to write your show
too you say Michael you know I'm sure
you don't have enough on your plate you
when when you finish writing your show
Michael how about you write my show too
I don't think so Buster unless unless
you you know you're paying very well in
which case reach out to my agent we can
talk about it okay let's get to some
mailbag questions the old-fashioned way
uh we've got a question up uh hey
Michael my fiance is in the union and is
an army veteran
and has worked very hard for what he has
and works hard to protect it he's really
insisting we get a prenup before getting
married because of horror stories from
fellow union workers slash military
friends no matter how many times I tell
him
that would never happen as I don't
believe in divorce he is still really
insisting on it I don't like the whole
idea of a prenup in general I think it
completely defeats the institution of
marriage and undermines it looking for
any ideas on how to change his mind I've
known from the moment we met I was
supposed to marry him even though he
didn't thanks girl born in the wrong
generation so is that I think that is
that an anonymous yeah that's from
girlborn in the wrong generation okay
great question
great question I share your hatred of
prenuptial agreements I think they're
awful and I do think they undermine the
institution of marriage
but I sympathize with your husband or
your fiancee
because he's he's coming at it from the
perspective of
men get totally burned in cases of
divorce and they basically have no power
and the woman can just choose to walk
off willy-nilly and then take half the
man's stuff and take the man's kids and
that's terrible and so puts men at a
terrible disadvantage so my solution to
this
is yes you should you you should
consider a prenuptial agreement but not
the usual kind of prenuptial agreement
the usual prenuptial agreement makes it
easier and simpler to get divorced my
version of a prenuptial agreement would
make it basically impossible to get
divorced so I think a good prenuptial
agreement to sign in our decadent
licentious day and age would be we agree
not to get divorced
and here are all the reasons we're not
going to get divorced and hear all the
things that are going to make it much
harder to get divorced and finally we
will not have a no-fault divorce quote
unquote no fault divorce no such a thing
exists of course but we won't use that
legal mechanism and
if we do get divorced it will be because
one party forces the divorce and here's
The Clincher of it whichever party
initiates the divorce forfeits
everything
forfeits claims to money forfeits claims
to the kids forfeits claims to the house
forfeits claims to everything and so the
effect of this prenuptial agreement
would be
to to strengthen the institution of
marriage now you could of course you
could have some sort of carve outs there
you know if my husband becomes you know
a belligerent serial killing
wife-beating Maniac you know maybe
there's a little carve out here for some
kind of a separation but assuming that
that's not going to happen and putting
that sort of thing you don't seem
particularly concerned about that I
would I would use the prenuptial
agreement
against its intended purpose which is to
destroy marriage I would use it to
strengthen marriage and I think this is
a political lesson for all of us
we live in an age with all sorts of
challenges forced on us by our
disgusting liberal culture so what we
ought to do is we have to play the hand
that we're dealt right you can you you
live in the society that you live in you
have the tools available to you that are
available to you we should use those to
undermine our decadent disgusting
liberal society and the prenuptial
agreement is a great way to do it use
the prenup which is a tool of divorce
to basically make divorce impossible I
think that would be a brilliant way to
use it for and I I think it's very
brilliant because I came up with it from
Andrew hey Michael
I was having a conversation with a
friend about men's clothing the other
day and wanted your take I personally
believe no man who cares about his
dignity should wear shorts skinny jeans
or ankle socks outside of the house do
you agree with this what do you think
men should wear from day to day
I agree with that
totally agree with that as a rule now
there are some exceptions
exceptions prove rules but if you're
going
to Bermuda you have to wear silly
colored pastel shorts you have to
payeze
you know when in When in Rome do what
the Romans do
if you are at some silly sort of waspy
event on a boat in the middle of summer
then maybe there is some occasion to
where shorts with some kind of silly
pattern of lobsters or sailboats okay
maybe
but as a rule yes grown men should not
wear shorts
uh those silly little ped socks you know
I guess there's some practical use for
them but generally no avoid them I I
almost never wear socks just as a rule
it's fine boat shoes loafers Topsiders
that's fine you don't need socks for
that
yeah of course ideally you know some
kind of a collared shirt outside the
house unless you want to you know unless
you want you walking around the Bronx
you want to wear like some cool kind of
Italian sweatsuit or something yeah
obviously there are there are exceptions
here but as a rule you are completely on
the right track
I've been told this is shocking to me
some people disagree with things that I
have said and there is a tick tocker who
has disagreed with something that I have
said so informed my producers this
morning they informed me of this fact so
we will be going over it on the member
block and of course we'll be going over
because it is Friday the rest of the
mailbag questions so the rest of the
show is continuing now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]